i understand the anxiety about getting a
breakthrough case
but as the science makes clear
if you're fully vaccinated
you're highly protected from severe
illness
even if you get covet-19
in fact recent data indicates
there is only one confirmed positive
case per 5 000 fully vaccinated
americans per day
you're as safe as possible
and we're doing everything we can to
keep it that way keep it that way keep
you safe
that's where boosters come in
the shots that give you even more
protection than after your second shot
now
i know there's been some confusion about
boosters so let me be clear
last month
our top government doctors announced
an initial plan
for booster shots for vaccinated
americans they believe that the booster
is likely to provide the highest level
of protection yet
of course
the decision
of which booster shots to give when to
start them and who will give them
will be left completely to the
scientists at the fda in the centers for
disease control
but while we wait
we've done our part
we bought enough boosters enough booster
shots and the distribution system is
ready to administer them
as soon as they are authorized
those eligible will be able to get a
booster right away
in tens of thousands of sites across the
sites across the country for most
americans
at your nearby drugstore and for free